all right time for some pft props
week one
tampa bay four and a half point underdog
at new orleans sean payton said that tom
brady's already texted him to say
you're the favorites if you had to put
money down now
the saints at home
with the buccaneers coming to town
marquee game week one who you got
i would take this real possibility
there'd be no fans there exactly take
that take that you know into account
there could be a lesser crowd there
could be no crowd plus four and a half
feels like with no crowd that line will
absolutely change so i'll air on that
side and i think the bucks i mean the
bucks
were
you know tom brady's not going to a team
that was horrendous last year their
defense was pretty good and they have
some incredible offensive weapons they
what did they finish nine and seven when
a quarterback threw 30 interceptions so
the bucks are gonna be good
seven and nine but the buck's gonna be
good
the saints typically lay an anger too
early in the year as well i've got that
memory in recent years where it just
takes them a while to get started and if
you do remove the fans from the
conversation in this fanduel line of
plus 4.5 for tampa bay if there isn't
going to be fans i think that line's
going to move quickly and there was an
item last week i think it was in the
philadelphia inquirer big cat about the
impact of no fans on the betting lines
because the rule of thumb is three
points for home field advantage right
now in some places it's more like
seattle or kansas city but you get that
bump if you're playing the game at home
you take away the crowd that bump is
going to change now of course the other
team's still traveling to you and you're
not traveling so there's some advantage
there but you take away you take away
the inability of the offense to run the
offense the way it would like to run the
offense that's going to change the game
especially with uh tom brady in a new
offense new offensive guys being able to
talk to all of them in a in a you know
place like the superdome would be
incredible
and as la it's it's as loud as a playoff
game week one if tom brady is coming to
town to take on breeze that place is
going to be amped up if they have fans
in there the nfl still holds out hope
that they will be able by september to
let people come to the game there's
there's some research being done when it
comes to what it means to have the
coronavirus antibody and it could be it
could be by the time we get to labor day
weekend
they'll be able to tell people hey if
you test positive for this antibody
you're good to go you can't spread it
you can't catch it you are fine go live
your life go to football games and go
fill up stadiums all right what's juice
here tom brady's over under at 29 and a
half passing touchdowns or drew brees
over under at 30 and a half passing
touchdowns big cat
ooh
i go with brady again i i think brady's
offense has more overall weapons you
know uh
michael thomas is up there for best
receivers in the league but
and they have a great running game in
new orleans but with with gronk there
and mike evans
and godwin like they're the bruce arians
like this is going to be both teams are
going to try to push the ball downfield
and i would take tom brady in this one
yeah i think i will too and the other
side of it is look i
i know what i'm walking into and i will
do it consciously you never know how
much taysom hill is going to be on the
field this year as the saints
boom him so eight yeah 25
8 25 in the morning it took an hour 25
minutes before what took you so long
professed his love for taysom hill
all i'm pointing out is there's a
possibility that taysom hill will be on
the field more the pain that got 21
million over two years there's a there's
a possibility we'll see him a little bit
more and that could eat into the
statistics of drew brees that's no hot
take that's just reality how can you
deny that
oh i quick yawn i tried to eat it uh i
can't deny it
but do you love taste some help
i i just i just don't understand how
taysom hill became so polarizing for
football fans because nowhere he hasn't
played as a quarterback in the nfl and
people are comparing him to lamar
jackson and saying he's a franchise
quarterback it's not hard to figure out
where this came from
speaking of lamar jackson over under
past touchdowns 26 and a half last year
he led the league and i believe tied the
all-time ravens franchise record at 36.
i'll take over i'll take over i actually
uh i'll take over because jk dobbins is
gonna be
a guy who who changes their offense even
you know they've already ran the ball so
well but he can catch the ball and i'll
take over i think another year under his
belt he'll see the field a little bit
easier i think i think he will have i
don't know 30 30 touchdowns i'll say
yeah look i agree with you at 36 last
year and that was when
you know he was running a lot i think
the longer he plays the less we're going
to see him run because he's going to
develop as a passer he's going to see
the field better he's going to he's not
now they'll be designed runs but you
become less inclined to rely upon your
god-given athletic ability and escape
bad situations if you think maybe if you
just wait another second or two or buy
some time behind the line of scrimmage
ben roethlisberger's style you're going
to find a guy open down the field and i
think we're going to see that transition
especially if teams become more
committed to devising defenses aimed at
shutting down that run it's going to
create more opportunities in the passing
game so i'm surprised 26 and a half
is the number that seems a lot lower
than it should be considering it had 36
last year
also what's what's more likely lamar
jackson leads the league in touchdown
passes again
or he leads the league in rushing yards
he was sixth in rushing yards last year
i'd say touchdown passes again i don't i
mean he didn't lead the league in
russian yards
last year and like you just said i don't
think he will run as much i think
they'll probably try to start you know
uh protecting him a little bit more so
and it's you know the two things go hand
in hand
as he gets further in his career and he
feels more comfortable throwing the ball
and reading defenses and doing all that
his need to run will be lessened so i
think it will go higher higher
likelihood that he will throw lead the
league in touchdown passes like he did
last year than lead the league in
rushing yards where he was just six last
year
football is coming in just a few months
and i am convinced they will be playing
this year until then there are other
sports this weekend let's have some fun
with those nascar coca-cola 600 pardon
my take guest denny hamlin plus 900 to
win his second race in a row your
thoughts well
pardon my take guest denny hammond on
today's show also guaranteed victory so
take it
yeah i still i can't
look at that mask oh my goodness so
funny
so funny you know that's the thing about
the masks there there is it just
unleashes a new level of potential
creativity for people i think it's
awesome that's a great great mask uh do
you wear a mask when you got in public
i do i absolutely do yeah i don't go out
in public so it's not relevant to me
although today i've got to run some
errands i think i i have a couple of
masks to choose from i have one with
little footballs on it and i have one
with little baseballs on it i wonder
which of the two i'll choose
don't do the baseballs then someone
might actually ask you about you know
baseball and you won't know how to
answer
exactly all right uh bundesliga the
german soccer league that is playing
games with no fans in the stands bayern
munich versus i'm talked i'm talked is
that's probably how they say it i'm not
being i'm not mocking that's i'm trying
to do justice to the i'm talked
frankfurt plus 700 for a draw plus 1400
for a win uh do you care first of all uh
yeah i do care i've been betting the
over in every single game blindly so yes
i can i will take the over whatever it
is just do it i i just like turning on
the tv and seeing a ball move on the
screen
what's the over under for a soccer match
point five
no
stops two and a half three three and a
half right around three and a half no
way three and a half
yeah every game is one one to nil i've
heard one danielle more times than i've
ever ever heard any score combination in
any other sport one to nil one you're a
hater all the time you're a hater all
right there's a little golf this weekend
as well tiger woods and peyton manning
minus 220 against phil mickelson and tom
brady plus 170 who you got
oh
who do you think is better do you think
tom brady's better than peyton manning
what how does that one break down
i assume peyton manning is better at
golf because tom brady's obsessed with
football when the hell does tom brady
golf
yeah
how does he how does he ever get good
enough at golf without putting time into
it time that would be taken away from
his ongoing obsession with football
peyton manning what else is he doing
at that price i'd take the underdog just
because what i mean it's
it's a fun match that doesn't really
mean anything so take the underdog you
know what i mean why would you why would
you lay that much
with it with a favorite when it's like
who even knows what's gonna happen who
knows how these guys are exactly
i i hate to agree with you but i
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports